well if you're caught by surprise when
both Tropicana and I-15 are completely
closed for a few days next month you
can't say we didn't warn you yeah
especially Nate is traffic anchor Nate
Tanenbaum has the very latest on what
the Nevada Department of Transportation
they're calling this Tropicana
[Music]
alrighty here are the dates that both
Tropicana and I-15 will be completely
closed next month Tropicana will be
closed between Dean Martin and New York
New York from January 22nd until January
30th the I-15 will be shut down between
Flamingo and Russell from 10 p.m January
27th until 5 a.m January 30th the Nevada
Department of transportation's Justin
Hopkins it's not just Lane restrictions
and it's not just a traffic headache it
is actually full stop 24 7 closures of
Tropicana for eight days and of I-15 for
three full days MDOT Project Director
Lynette Russell once we close Tropicana
on the 22nd it is very much about
removals
yeah she's talking about removing the
start of that flyover ramp that goes
from the south 15 to eastbound trop
there's going to be a lot more about all
of this as the dates get closer but this
thing's not being called drop a canner
for nothing and ndot's hoping that
you'll consider downloading the I-15
Drop app you'll have everything you need
to know at your fingertips buckle up
drive carefully please put down the
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com